on fondait sur le stand de dj hi pour
parler du mavic 2
[Musique]
7h30 du matin dimanche matin je pars de
berlin c'était le dernier jour de l'ifa
hier mais j'ai veillé tout super cool et
je voulais partager avec vous bougez un
vol dans deux heures et demie à trucs
comme ça
et justement je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui dj hype à ce que vous dites
j'irais la sortie est pas très longtemps
le mavic deux pros et magique de zoom
sont des drones grand public sont justes
topissime et je voulais vous les montrez
vous verrez pas de plans du film est
depuis drones on a mis la carte micro sd
directement dans drones hafid est plein
de trucs super malheureusement et rien
sur la carte ça marche pas
vous allez voir néanmoins il ya plein de
trucs super cool et puis pour voir des
images de dj hi
je vous invite à aller voir directement
sur leur page youtube vous trouverez
plein de trucs aussi super sur internet
mais vous allez voir parce que on a
parlé dj hi sur les drones toute façon
un taux global et on a vu plein de
choses cool donc vous invite à regarder
[Musique]
on est sur le stand de dj avec olivier
merci olivier de m'accueillir
c'est aurélien donc di gioia a présenté
de nouveaux produits il ya quelque temps
à new york
ma vie 2 est ce que tu peux présenter ce
projet ça s'est produit parce que il ya
exactement donc magic 2 poids 2 parce
qu'il ya deux produits à le magic de pro
à les filles caméra technologie à ce
black donc
géant suédois des caméras qu'on ne
présente plus est quand même
park à ses prestigieuses de caméras ont
interdit la technologie he has all
blacks tout cas tout ce qui est sûr le
call of duty et la coloration est
vraiment ce qui se fait avec ça un
capteur 1 pouces est très fort en terme
de ce tableau lumineux lead exactement
ok donc vraiment idéal même pour des
photos
que faites vous
impressionnant il est vraiment grand
lalla salma une belle bête il ya
vachement devancé vous sentez dessous
c'est vraiment incroyable
il a une stabilité des complètement
dingue vraiment génial
hra pharma qui est un peu plus grand que
l'ancien par contre il est gavé de
capteurs tous les côtés il est juste
incroyable je le vois volé il ya il fait
des images
bref je suis là c'est le modèle zoom
vous allez vraiment pouvoir aller
chercher des choses en profondeur dans
l'image il ya aussi le modèle pro tiens
voilà dj am nous régale cette année
encore une fois avec des produits qui
sont au juste sublime hyper stabiliser
et franchement c'est génial on a aussi
le magic de zoom
hu est toujours maintenu qu'il ya un
zoom et qui permet de faire des effets
assez extraordinaires comme
dédommagement ce qu'on peut faire ce que
scorsese pouvait faire sur certains
films on peut le faire aujourd'hui avec
un manic 2 où nous invite à regarder
vraiment les vidéos je vais mettre ma
prestation comme ça vous verrez les deux
nouveaux drones mais aujourd'hui
commander sur site ign.com avait pas
encore disponible dans les magasins mais
qui arrive incessamment sous peu
parce que je lis j'écoute vraiment ces
produits c'est qu'il est prêt
on mêle bien pareil dans la description
on pourra les voir pour y aller quand
même une galerie de photos ont été
prises par les derniers drones de dj
house avec les photos sont franchement
incroyable ce souffle
c'est juste une photo qui est
complètement incroyable vous avez pas si
vous voyez d'un détail des voitures qui
sont tout juste alors une vue aérienne
qui est franchement superbe elle est si
vrai sinon ça qui est génial avec ce
produit c'est de pouvoir tout l'étendue
des possibilités puis surtout la qualité
le rendu final c'est vraiment top que ce
soit aussi bien sûr un outil purement
vidéo pour aller faire du tracking pour
aller s'amuser pour du loisir que pour
un usage professionnel c'est vraiment un
régal
[Musique]
le prix de ma fille deux gros est à 1449
euros
quel est le zoom et à 1249 euros dont
200 euros d'écart entre les deux caméras
à vous de choisir si l'on souhaitait
avoir la meilleure caméra
mais qui sont traqués d'euros
un drone un peu plus versatile un peu
fun mais avec une caméra qui reste aussi
vraiment
[Musique]
et
pour toi la vraie différence entre les
deux va se jouer au niveau de la caméra
des hommes avec le magic de pro et note
la plus l'expérience utilisateur qui
change
l'expérience utilisateur est la même
c'est après si on a le
faire un peu plus de choses un peu plus
fun un peu plus fameux dooly's où les
obligera peut faire un peu sinon vous
soyez en afrique où adp jirane autour de
vous ça vous évite de trop pour
accrocher pourquoi
des plantes
on peut avoir une fois combien fois 2e
en optique auquel encore après photo en
il se sert des pixels mende utilisé sur
la vidéo quelqu'un qui écoute peu après
a grandi on peut filmer en full hd sans
problème est ensuite allé chercher
voilà au kenya des améliorations du
magic 2 par rapport à la première
génération c'est aussi une conséquence
notamment aux termes de l'article
ajoutant artificiel
je suis dit là qu'il craque 2 en termes
d'événements d'obstacles on a
aujourd'hui pour capteurs aux capteurs
infrarouges
permet de visualiser le terrain sur
lequel ont atterri d'accord ok bon c'est
grâce à une reconnaissance de terrain si
terrain est pas propice itecor il
atterrit paris fin et surtout il va
vraiment reconnaître l'endroit où il est
parti aussi pour pouvoir atterrir
effectivement beaucoup plus silencieux
autonomie de trente et une minutes
voilà donc des années le restaurant
termes de sécurité aussi en terme
d'expérience de stabilité tu me parles
il a déjà identifié tout à l'heure en me
disant par exemple une voiture qui passe
sous un tunnel le mavic à la base va
s'arrêter parce qu'il a perdu avant son
suivant la voiture avec un petit frein
clarec celui là il va réfléchir et se
dire si renault au tunnel il ya
pardonnez moi non plus côté je vais
aller voir tout sera exactement il a
anticipé en fait que la voiture va
ressortir un moment donné de l'autre
côté du tunnel n'a gardé que pousse
vraiment cette intelligence artificielle
alors qu'on puisse voler
pousse les mains libres avec un
un compagnon qui est
leur design aujourd'hui effectivement
les solutions grand public mais aussi tu
m'a montré les commissions
professionnelles pour que le voyage
n'est donc ni dia et à 12 ans
aujourd'hui et on est de plus en plus
présent dans le monde du cinéma à
hollywood sur les tournages dans les
plateaux avec des
des stabilisateurs comme le ronaldo
lequel on peut tout ces deux grosses
caméras et qui permet de faire beaucoup
mieux qu'avant et
notamment aussi de tous les
gamme d'accessoires comme le dit cherry
faut il dit ah oui on va te montrer
ok voilà bon merci beaucoup a ajouté où
il y en a rajouté
vous avez des questions mais bien sûr
continuer à regarder des vidéos c'est un
test assez peu seulement et puis voilà
at il rappelé avant d'annoncer ma vidéo
géniale
[Musique]
merci à l'équipe de dj haye pour avoir
très bien reçue c'est super gentil donc
ces drones
on va essayer de les tester
prochainement a pas forcément tout de
suite tout de suite mais d'ici quelques
temps dès qu'on a un petit moment en pop
up on va le tester puis on va les voir
en conditions réelles
ce qu'on peut faire avec voilà je trouve
ça vraiment génial et puis surtout de
voir toutes ces techniques qui sont
embarqués dans ces produits c'est juste
incroyable viège pas ce que vous en
pensez vous vous devez avoir vous avez
déjà eu probablement tester détourné 10
jan si c'est le cas dites moi quels
produits dites moi ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous les trouvez que je
cherche mon chum en même temps donc tu
fais ne vous inquiétez pas c'est sur la
route à gauche
dites moi ce que vous en pensez qu'elle
drones vous aimez est-ce que vous
utilisez un drone dj hell pourquoi pas
aussi une autre marque car ils s'étaient
pas vous marquez tout ça et bien sûr en
commentaire comme ça on fait avancer un
petit peu l'histoire
[Musique]
on parle aussi de robotique on est juste
devant le stand de
uteq tqs et aux vélos pour vous montrer
la rue bec
déjà rencontré quand j'étais aux 6es
j'ai fait une vidéo sur l'euro alors une
tech un son de loof fait graver des
petits robots s'est déjoué mais en train
vraiment développer aussi de la
robotique
notamment on a vu votre coeur ou mac
janvier aux crs
super intéressant comme solution je vous
invite d'ailleurs à les visionner cette
vidéo va faire un petit tour c'est vrai
que la robotique va se développer de
plus en plus alors on va en parler
beaucoup sur la chaîne je testais en
rambo laisser quelques jours donc vous
habite
bonnet et à rester connectés en robot
qui va rester au studio pour voir revoir
régulièrement comme ça va vraiment
comprendre les usages voit ce qu'on peut
en faire
pourquoi la robotique peut nous aider au
quotidien ça franchement c'est super
intéressant
j'en ai parlé il ya quelques jours il ya
une nouvelle marque qui arrive en france
sur des smartphones mais je découvre et
je suis très heureux de voir qui a pas
que du smartphone c'est la marque condor
donc qu'en dehors on va en parler parce
qu'on a testé les produits il ya des
smartphones ya trois gammes différentes
et puis oui il ya d'autres croyances ça
ça n'arrive pas toutes en france vous
avez aussi
eux qui sont jusque là
av de l'électroménager a priori ces
produits sont pas disponibles pour le
moment sur le marché français est en
tout cas pour ce qui va être du
smartphone condor est arrivé on va
reparler beaucoup dans les temps à venir
donc une fois de plus les invite à faire
une chose c'est à vous abonner
restez connectés et en plus de ça condor
a même une télé en 8k tout simplement
[Musique]